what's going on guys this is Robin and I
am so excited for infinity war I am I'm
so hyped for infinity war I've been
sitting here trying to figure out like
what I think might happen and we just
didn't episode of the weekly poll so
make sure you guys go check out Sal over
comment pop and Benny over at comic
story and we were just like like he'll
in time talking about like what we
thinks gonna happen an infinity war what
our theories were who he thinks gonna
die and the whole nine yards and it was
awesome because with movies like
infinity war there's so much that can
happen like like my theory for example
is that like everything we've seen in
the trailer happens in like the first 45
minutes of the movie and then it just
takes off into space after that and it's
just like I mean it's entirely possible
and it's so cool it probably won't I
mean we'll probably end up seeing like
the other superheroes get decimated by
like the Black Order but like to me that
the cool thing about this to me like
like vanos has to pop right like there
has to be something about Thanos people
just have to be like oh my god dude a
nose was here like everyone's gonna die
like it has to have that whole you know
that whole feel to it and and in my mind
when I when I think about this my first
thought is okay so like the scene with
Loki and Thor happens that like the very
beginning of the movie right like that's
my whole thought my thought is like
danos basically invades the ship of Loki
and Thor alongside the Black Order and
he just like dominates Thor and it's
just like damn like you know but but the
caveat is well he would have succeeded
if he had his hammer like Thor would
have it would have worked if he had his
hammer so that's like the first thing
they kind of play on a little bit and so
it's like okay so so Thanos dominates
Thor and Loki and basically tells Loki
like if you don't give me the Cosmic
Cube I'm gonna kill for like if you
don't give me the space stone I'm gonna
kill him and so Loki basically hands it
over and so so Thanos has that which
explains how he's teleporting around
from there like they arrive on earth and
then like the earth superheroes aren't
really considered to be anybody
worthwhile like Thanos would never waste
his time worrying about her superheroes
so he sends the black order and he's
like go you know get out there you know
Corvus glaive Proxima midnight
evany more super giant and black dwarf
get out there and just like like you
know take everybody out and so we end up
having like the Black Order that shows
up on earth and for the most part like
they're kind of holding their own I mean
I would say the black order will
probably dominate most of the earth
superheroes in the sense that like like
the heroes in New York like the Avengers
will probably get to get you know
readily like get their backsides handed
to them readily and then from there
we'll jump into like the forces kind of
marsh
and people trying to you know turn
understand what's going on I think that
that will ultimately lead to like a
battle in Wakanda and that that'll lead
like the huge thing where we see like
everybody charging but I think they're
all gonna be charging at Thanos I think
that's gonna be the huge thing like
they're all gonna go charging at Thanos
and and I think that's cool because like
my it'll basically be like the black
order either is destroyed by the
Avengers like the black waters dead
which means that US has to respond or
like the black order keeps getting
crushed
and so that us is like like that was
like okay like we have to do something
like the essence of stepping in with it
with like the black water not being able
to defeat what's left of like the
marshal or superheroes in Wakanda
because the technologic technologic too
advanced or whatever the case may be
like ultimately Thanos shows up and I
think that's like Thanos's moment right
because it's the one thing we all want
to see like it's the one thing we all
want to see it's one thing to see Fano
slide send the Black Order in and it's
like okay cool Thanos has the Infinity
Gauntlet and like you know blinks out
half the life in the universe but I
think that what Marvel is gonna try to
capitalize here and capitalize on here
is the idea that like Dallas is like
this indestructible guy like this this
godly powerful guy that no one's ever
faced off against before that like no
one's ever beep of like no one's written
to like the Avengers haven't faced off
against anything like fan O's before and
I think that's kind of what like
Marvel's shooting for and if they do
that like if that's what they're getting
for then what you do is you grab the
nose you sit him to what conduct right
like the last battle is like in Wakanda
the last is like the battle for Earth
isn't what Conda so theater shows up
there and and like the earth superheroes
like okay cool let's get him you know
and they they get them and Thanos just
like decimates them all I mean just like
wrecks them all like like just is just
like done like they do do that be the
crazy that the craziest thing ever
wouldn't it do them no I'm getting so
excited maybe the craziest thing ever
like like imagine that imagine that for
you for exactly you have all this do
your superheroes fight against Thanos
and like like the whole the Hulk shows
up he's like man you want some I'll give
you some and like crushes the Hulk and
then Thor shows always like man you want
some I'll give you some to son they're
like like since Thor find out of the
picture do they behave either do to be
the baby the most boss thing dude annals
your sales mannered come come feel me
that'd be the coolest thing that was
just like just question everybody just
like record record everybody the whole
thing do that that'd be that'd be so
boss like that'd be so boss famous just
like wrecking the earth superheroes just
like just crushing them just absolutely
crushing up and
just like dude how can we beat a guy
like this and so so okay so so then
there's like defeats all the other
superheroes Captain America's the last
one left I would imagine this imagine
Captain America is so hyped right now
Captain America is the last one left
all right so so Captain America jumps in
and he's like come on Thanos you know
freedom American life so like like like
Captain America and Thanos you facing
off like and Captain America is like
okay you know I've stood up against
tyrants like you at them was like not
like me and like just smashes Captain
America shield right just like shatters
the shield of Captain America he
destroys freedom so he crushes the
shield of Captain America and like if
the audience if we saw that we would
just be like my god he crushed the
shield of Captain America
it's like Jim Ross from the WWE is like
God not gonna be the greatest thing ever
so so so like the shield gets destroyed
and Thanos just like crushes Captain
America like that scene that you see
what Captain America's like oh you know
like that whole thing that's going on
that happens for like 30 seconds and if
that was just like done and just crushes
Captain America and so it's like dude he
readily like crush their superheroes
like they don't have a chance and so
he's like okay so like so then he ends
up like grabbing the grabbing like
Captain America she or not governorship
going to double Khanna takes the soul
stone and leaves all right now now
that'd be cool
it all happens in like the first 45
minutes right that'd be nuts if it
happens in the first 45 minutes because
the other questions everybody wants like
here's here's the thing that we don't
that we don't have an answer to yet the
Power Stone the power stones words and
our that's that's that's what the Nova
Corps now here's a cool thing
all right all right bear with me here
here's the cool thing so so Marvel is
like toying with the idea of the Nova
Corps and Sal overcome a pop head alone
we had a super cool idea with this all
right he was he was like they're they're
toying with the idea of the Nova Corps
so like annihilation like like just give
us the Nova Corps annihilation storyline
you guys don't know what that is one of
the greatest stories ever annihilation
was like like it was what was it it was
a nihilist leading like basically an
army of bugs into the universe and
trying to kill everything but like
Richard Ryder is like the last of the
Nova Corps because in the whole
annihilation thing maybe is my Legion
conquest like the entire Nova Corps gets
obliterated he's the last one left and
that dude I would I would love to see
that right but it depends on what kind
of Nova they're gonna go with if they go
with Sam Alexander
oh dude if they go what's it matter if
they go Sam I said okay okay Sam
Alexander cool is 12 year old kid ever
all right Sam Alexander becomes the new
Nova all right here's what you do you
have Sam Alexander on earth Sam
Alexander's father is part of the Nova
Corps and he's one of the members of the
Nova Corps who's just like totally
destroyed when Thanos like obliterates
anarchist come back come on man let me
tell you something man let me tell you
something now no one believes the Nova
Corps would stand a chance against
Thanos if you believe that Nova Corps
was saying yeah it's the same chance
against analyst I would tell you like I
don't man they they they are not
prepared they're not ready for the
onslaught that fan else is gonna bring
so so okay so imagine the Stannis like
defeats all the earth superheroes in
like 45 minutes here's what I'm saying
like like Daniels chilling up and crush
the air superheroes that's like a five
minute fight like it's it's no it's it's
nothing it's it's nothing man like like
like the the the black order shows up in
the fight against I don't see on earth
like they're fighting against the black
like black quarters fighting the super
years and the black warriors kind of you
know holding their own or whatever and
then Thanos was just like okay I've had
enough of this and he just shows up and
he's like done done done and it takes
the Infinity Gauntlet Leafs like do that
that'd be that'd be the coolest thing
all right so that that fights like five
minutes long dude that's just five
minutes long like it's the shortest
fight ever
all right so he crushes zero superheroes
leaves and then heads to Xander and it's
like man I even had the Power Stone yet
on another Power Stone yet like imagine
what up man no matter what I'm gonna do
with power stuff so he shows up at Sand
arc right and then just like by himself
with his inherent powers like just
crushes throughs and are like crushes
through the Nova Corps they're like all
right everybody come on we're the Nova
Corps let's all get together and let's
fight and make our little energy net
like we did in guardians of the galaxy
and Thanos like don't give a damn it
like just rolls through and just the
crushes like just decimates the entire
Nova Corps just bodies everywhere just
like bodies all over the place just
bodies laying all dead everything is
just like just walks in takes the Power
Stone and leaves and then like has the
it has the whole Infinity Gauntlet
assembly and like the whole time titles
have been here he's been talking to
somebody you can't see right you know
and it's like it's like man we can't see
you know it's like ministers going crazy
man he's hearing voices man like it like
they're menaces go crazy so like so so
stano's they look like like at the end
of the whole thing dances like I was
like does this please you like the are
you finally please and like you end up
finding out he's talking to mistress
death but she doesn't do anything she
just turns and looks away from her and
then it's just like he's like well then
I know it will make you happy
snaps his fingers and all like half-life
the universe just bleeds out and it's
like dude you know like like like
they're so screwed man
like half the life the universe's gone
like this is a kind of power we're
talking about son like man this is this
is crazy amounts of power that's going
on here like it's just this is this is
bonkers and so you only have like a
handful of heroes left here's a question
got asked here's a question I got asked
here if it's gonna go like Infinity
Gauntlet we're like Adam warlock was
marshaling all their superheroes
together and he was like okay
superheroes you go be cannon fodder
because the end of the day not gonna do
[ __ ] so like you you became and fodder
you go over there through the greatest
part of a fittest man the greatest part
of Infinity Gauntlet okay so the whole
battle is going on right like the whole
battle where the superheroes is going on
and and in like like Silver Surfer is
standing next to Adam warlock it's over
surfers like come on man put me in coach
I got this I can do it man and Adam or
like - no he's like no you stay here
you stay here next to me I'll tell you
when to go so the battle is raging on
and Thanos keeps getting more and more
arrogant as he's winning right now he's
like backhanded Captain America's shield
to pieces and he's turning like like
quasar somebody where's our goes to
attack him and he just like looks like
transmogrifies him into children's block
she literally re materializes them in
the children's watch retransmitted
children's block and then like like
Thanos goes to punch somewhere like
raises his hand up and goes to punch
someone and and like Adam warlocks like
now and like he sends us over server so
we suffer goes fly and this is like oh
he goes flying another thing and like
don't stir grab the garlic from Thanos
his hand and like misses it by that much
they must realize what was going on he
was like nope and then he moved to gaunt
and it's like oh dude it's crazy like
this it's man man let me tell you some
man do this madness movie man man this
movie's gonna be bonkers I'm just saying
like this might like those that's my
theory for infinity war like it like I
mean I could see some surfer like I'm a
big man be cool for something man let me
tell you something see sober surfer man
imagine Ames like a post-credits scene
right like infinity going 80 war happens
like everything like I also having
Thanos blanks out half-life in universe
and the whole audience is just like dude
this is this is some crazy [ __ ] is this
bonkers man this is absolutely bonkers
like like everything's going nuts and
then there's like a post-credits scene
and you end up finding out like the
whole battle was being witnessed by
Silver Surfer and then he just takes off
to go find let you go tell Galactus
what's going on you just see like a
silver street fly through space it would
be like mad son I'll beat man I'd be mad
be freaked out man there's no surface
son man young man y'all be real man
y'all been
ready man man y'all better be running
that I know and in the end they're
depending on they're gonna show up
they're gonna try to attack Thanos like
man he better not attack Dallas man
he's gonna be mad at you like man you
guys are gonna get rekt you go get you
and get deuced all over like this dude
man I'm excited man I'm mad I'm sorry
from so excited people but it is an
exciting time to for this cuz it Madison
Tennessee infinity war movie man
merciful movie man man man I'm excited
man I'm like anyway I think I should new
here to Kyler's explain make sure you
guys hit the sub button to become part
of the Rob core if you guys enjoy this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]